[Music]
there are lots of reasons to go to war
food
sex power
Stakes are high
winners enjoy the spoils losers can be
humiliated exiled
or eating and eventually even the
strongest meet their match
are some of the world's deadliest
animals and they're ready for combat
foreign
the dominant animal nearly always gains
The Spoils of War
where they're fighting over food mates
or territory no one as it is good as the
alphas but getting to that Elite status
isn't easy
and neither is staying there
especially if you're trying to overcome
Africa's most dangerous alpha male
or the hippopotamus
males can weigh over four thousand
pounds
he's fast that bulky body can reach
speeds of 30 miles per hour
fierce
hippos have been known to kill people
though they're vegetarians
very territorial vegetarians
dominant hippo bulls usually preside
over a territory that includes a pod of
females
[Music]
this old male is king of this stretch of
the river and has the Battle Scars to
prove it
Bachelor is ready to Stage a coup
and he gets right to the point
fighting off the old male's tail
hippo teeth are formidable weapons
the four tusk-like canines can grow up
to a foot long in their razor sharp
those jaws can open four feet wide and
snap closed with a bite force of almost
one ton
enough to crush a crocodile or take out
a power balloon add to that a 500 pound
head and it's like facing off with a
very angry armored tank
already injured the senior doesn't even
try to overcome his attacker
45 minutes the young male continues his
assault
he only stops when the old leader
submits to his rule allowing him to
mount him in a show of dominance
it's the ultimate defeat
the old Warrior has lost his tail and
his mates
the new king of the river opens wide to
Proclaim his victory
then he bombs his new territory with
feces
the old alpha male slinks off in defeat
have lost the battle but to other
predators
He's Still The King
and in the cold-blooded Realm of the
reptile world
battles over mating rights are just as
heated
when out on the hunt in its tropical
domain
the monitor lizard likes to fly solo
his forked tongue helps him sniff out
decaying fish flesh and females
but when Love Is in the Air potential
suitors come out of the woodwork
and with this quick tempered lizard that
means instant competition
[Applause]
[Music]
these scaly battles can last for up to
45 minutes
foreign
this isn't a fight to the death but
rather a display of dominance and
strength
a heavyweight Sumo match with claws
where the loser gets pinned underwater
the triumphant male gets the girl but he
better watch out
female monitors are just as ready to
scrap they'll fight their mates for food
[Music]
comes to survival amongst these lizards
there's no such thing as one big happy
family
the wrestling bouts of the monitor
lizard seem almost sporting when
compared with the brutal fighting of the
gelatin monkey
[Music]
in the High Mountain Meadows of Ethiopia
marauding gangs of male gelatin monkeys
are on the lookout for females
[Music]
these Bachelor bands are an alpha male's
worst nightmare
foreign
this Alpha is clearly outnumbered
[Music]
but he steps up to defend his position
gelata harems can range from small
family units of 12.
troops numbering in the hundreds
that's a lot of monkeys to take care of
[Music]
he fires his first warning shot flipping
his lip in a clear display of aggression
[Music]
but the Invaders ignore it so he takes
matters into his own hands
and fleas to Higher Ground
but he has to come down eventually
[Music]
the only solution
make a break for it
[Music]
when he returns to his Harem he
reaffirms his bonds with some grooming
gel at a female stay in their family
units for life
banding together to forage groom and
raise their young
it's a woman's world where the males can
be replaced
with a mob closing in the harem's leader
resorts to a chilling tactic he picks up
an infant and jumps back into the fight
he may be trying to entice the females
to LEAP to the infant's Aid and help
chase the bachelor's off
but the plan backfires the single males
attack anyway and the baby is hurt
when he drops the injured infant he
faces an even more enraged enemy
his own family
[Music]
try some last-ditch grooming to appease
his females
but when the bachelor's return This Time
It's For Keeps
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the old leader heads for the Hills
these Fierce fights can go on for days
and inflict fatal battle wounds
[Music]
with the old Alpha thoroughly vanquished
the new leader wastes no time in
establishing dominance over his harem
final humiliation the old Alpha is
allowed to stick around
as a babysitter
battles over females can be dangerous
especially if a father is protecting his
own daughter
for this young male zebra the grasslands
of Botswana are Paradise
when they're full of food fun and
Phillies
but a single Bachelor doesn't get to
just walk up and woo his lady
he has to fight for her
foreign
s are made up of smaller family units
consisting of two to six mares they're
foals and one stallion
[Music]
the mother keeps her foes close
stallion also protects them
from predators and other zebras
but no father can really keep his
daughter from flirting with boys
a young Philly is ready to mate
and a bachelor stallion plans to win her
affection to mate with her he'll have to
entice her away from her father's herd
but this stallion isn't about to let his
little Philly run off with an unworthy
upstart
[Music]
to get past him The Suitor will have to
show his strength speed and cunning
he doesn't win this time he'll just have
to try again
this is the only way to establish his
own harem
neck wrestled the older stallion into
submission
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
continues into the
after hours of tussling the two
exhausted stallions call a truce
young one gets the girl
but he'll need to stay fighting Fit
until she conceives
other Bachelors may try to steal her
away
the urge to mate is usually the source
of conflict within the ranks and the
competition can be fierce
for a bull elephant seal bigger is
better
males can grow up to 20 feet long and
weigh over 8 000 pounds
but it's that long trunk-like snout that
really amps up the sex appeal
the Bulls use those massive noses to
broadcast one message this is my turf
and to mate here you have to get through
me
thank you
elephant seals are the sumo wrestlers of
the Marine World
battle bulk is everything and Champs win
it all
Gathering harems of 40 to 50 females
only one in 10 males will become an
alpha male and father pops
if this bachelor wants a sex life combat
is his only answer
time has come to start a fight
[Music]
[Applause]
the battle grows more intense than the
battered contenders take their fight to
the water
foreign
the Challenger gets a good thrashing
Alpha returns to his ladies for his
prize
multiple meetings
size and strength often carry the day
the insects prove that tiny can be
terrifying
[Music]
the insect world is home to some of the
planet's fiercest battles
the stakes are high
home young and food sources are under
constant threat for European honey bees
they live in colonies that are often
over thirty thousand strong constructing
hives filled with wax pollen larvae and
of course honey
a pretty valuable Bounty for an invading
Army
when a honeybee Hive faces off with
Asian giant hornets it takes just one
recon mission to start a war
when a single Hornet's Scout spots a
beehive she marks it with a pheromone
and then returns with a hit squad
these Giants are the world's largest
Hornet five times the size of the
average honeybee
and they're armed with a deadly venom
their sting feels like a hot nail being
driven into your flesh
foreign
clean
thousands of Defenders pour from The
Hive ready to give their lives in its
defense
[Music]
European honeybees have no way to stop
the onslaught
a single Hornet can kill as many as 40
bees a minute just 30 of them can
annihilate a colony of 30 000 bees in a
few hours
it isn't a battle
it's a massacre
[Music]
the ground is thick with the remnants of
their victims
penetrates into the inner sanctum of the
hive
with the hive's Defenders laid to waste
the Hornets gorged themselves on The
Spoils of War
[Music]
but honey Isn't the main prize
instead they carry away the honeybee
larvae and pupae which will feed their
young for weeks
[Music]
European honeybees May fight valiantly
but they haven't evolved any defenses
against these giant Invaders
the Japanese honeybees have come up with
a tactic to take on these deadly
intruders
it involves training and teamwork an
offensive attack aimed at a single
Hornet Scout
they have to Ambush her before she
releases any pheromones
if the Hornet manages to Signal her Army
the game is up
the bees wiggle their abdomens a dance
that signals their battle plan to the
hive
they lure the interloper in and then
they sworn
their jaws and stings are no match for
the huge hornet so instead the Swarm
turns up the heat
hundreds of bees begin to vibrate so
fast that they increase the temperature
to 117 degrees
a temperature The Hornet can't withstand
[Music]
they roast the Scout alive
and the secret location of the hive
dies with her
bees aren't the only insects plagued by
giant hornets
foreign
mantis can fall victim to this heavily
armed predator
and the Mantis is hardly defenseless
turn its head 180 degrees using its five
eyes for reconnaissance its powerful
front legs are used to seize prey and
clutch their victims in a vice-like grip
spikes instantly spear the prey pinning
it in place
but the Hornet is a killing machine
foreign
she's armed with much more than a lethal
sting
her compound eyes can see the slightest
movement sharp tarsal claws sees and
hold her victims and with just one slice
her powerful mandibles decapitate prey
The Hornet takes the offensive ripping
apart the madness's wings and flesh
[Music]
the Mantis tries to bite back
but it's too late
with deadly surgical Precision The
Hornet butchers her victim ripping it to
shreds
but before she can declare Victory she
has one final and brutal move
decapitation
she choose the manus's flesh into a pulp
and carries it home to the nest
a five-star dinner for her hungry larvae
nourishing the Next Generation has
created some Fierce Fighters
and a mother looking to feed her young
will do whatever it takes to make the
kill
[Music]
the potent Venom in this banded sea
snake can kill a scuba diver
[Music]
so most underwater Predators leave snake
off their daily menus
they're real danger comes from the sky
snake island off the coast of Malaysia
this little chunk of limestone plays
host to hundreds of sea snakes it's
Placid right now but don't be fooled
these snakes have come ashore to breed
and tonight the competition on this
island for potential mates will be
fierce
sea snakes usually spend most of their
time in water but they don't have gills
their lungs stretch almost the length of
their entire bodies to fill them they
have to swim to the surface to breathe
and that means they're vulnerable
this white-bellied sea eagle has young
to feed so it's on the hunt
armed with Keen vision and sharp talons
the eagle has perfected the snatch and
grab
and sea snake is one of her favorite
foods
foreign
[Music]
but this snake isn't about to play the
victim
as the eagle flies towards the nest with
her prize the snake starts to fight back
even in midair he can bite
if he manages to inject his Venom he
could kill his abductor
but biting an enemy in mid-air isn't
easy especially for a creature that
spends most of its time in the water
for this snake it
especially when facing down a hungry
eaglet
[Music]
snake may be lunch meat but the eagle
doesn't have time to relax
one of the seabird's biggest threats is
other eagles
it has to constantly defend its feeding
ground from freeloaders
A Lone Eagle Has Come to check out the
fishing
but this area belongs to this breeding
pair and they're not inclined to share
their calls act as a warning shot which
The Invader ignores
is taking his dinner from their turf
they're not putting up with it
it's time to launch the first defensive
volley
female takes Point dive bombing the
Intruder starting a mid-air tug of war
but she loses both the fight and the
fish
[Music]
so she tag teams with her male partner
foreign
the Intruder and the defending male fly
high looking for the advantage
then they locked talons
battle is on
this whirling is a display of dominance
force in bravado
the Eagles climb higher ready for
another round
it's an aerial game of chicken and
neither Eagle blinks
[Music]
the Intruder emerges unhurt but decides
to move on
their territory once again secure the
breeding pair takes a Victory lap
the precise maneuvers of many animal
battles are a matter of instinct
but for some young Fighters they have to
learn the hard way
foreign
like human teenagers adolescent lions
are awkward but eager
at this age they'll try to eat anything
[Music]
comes to hunting they still have a lot
to learn
baboons spend most of their time
foraging on the ground but in times of
danger they can take to the trees and
use them to their advantage
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
Lions have sharp claws but they're not
great climbers
but that doesn't stop these young lions
from trying
their potential prey doesn't seem too
worried
adult Lions rarely Chase baboons and the
youngsters are about to find out why
[Music]
first one gets stuck and there's no fire
department to come get this big cat out
of the tree
[Applause]
and the baboon has her own way of
telling these incompetent Hunters to get
lost
double as missiles
then she unleashes the ultimate chemical
weapon urine
and the overgrown Cubs beat a hasty
Retreat they've just learned an
important lesson
don't bother with baboons
on the plains of Africa these young
Lions can afford to learn by trial and
error
[Music]
but in the unforgiving void of the
Arizona desert
Instinct and precision Mark the
difference between life and death
in this harsh dry landscape temperatures
can reach 120 degrees
shade
it's high noon
and one of these two Gunslingers is
going to be pushing up daisies
battles here take place out in the open
and survival is never assured
when this red tail hawk faces off with a
rattlesnake it starts with a deadly
dance
with the Supple Grace of a matador the
hawk draws the snake's fire towards his
wing feathers where a bite would be
harmless
the snake positions himself for a strike
the hawk targets the snake's head
the hawk draws first
bullseye
the hawk shows no fear and no mercy
[Music]
the first strike often has the advantage
even on a much smaller scale
this wasp will do anything to feed her
Young
including taking on the baboon spider
these spiders aren't small they can grow
to the size of small birds and they can
take care of themselves
eight hairy legs a pair of sharp fangs
and a sticky Shield make up the big
arachnids Arsenal
but the WASP is undeterred she has
weapons of her own speed flight and a
deadly sting this spider is 3.5 ounces
of pure eight-legged protein
protein the WASP needs to feed her young
she invades the spider's burrow charging
right through its protective shield
the spider has no choice but to retreat
but he doesn't get far
in seconds the WASP paralyzes him the
Venom from her staying putting him into
a permanent coma
it's a big Feast but it isn't for her
the spider just became an incubator
the mother wasp will lay a single egg in
the spider's abdomen
when it hatches her larva will eat its
immobilized host alive
big spiders nourish the female wasp
larvae
small spiders sustain the males
after a week of gorging on arachnid meat
The larva will pupate until the next
summer to become the next generation of
spider Hunters
Victory often goes to the fastest
fighter but sometimes slow can be just
as deadly
the giant horse [ __ ] weighs over 11
pounds
that's a lot of mollusk
The Conch has a taste for snails
so when the tiny tulip snail spots one
of these behemoths it knows it's in
trouble
the snail tries to outrun the big hunter
but it's like a tiny shuttle facing off
with a star destroyer in a battle that
moves at a snail's pace
[Music]
finally it's overrun
the smell of digesting snail attracts
new scavengers
hermit crabs
[Music]
foreign
but the crabs aren't here for leftover
escargot they're after the Tulip snails
shell
hermit crabs use cast off shells to
protect their soft abdomens from
predators
they find an empty shell use their rear
legs to attach to its Central column and
right in when their current homes grow
tight they have to look for new real
estate
the competition is fierce
with the Conch ready to release the
shell the housing battle heats up
foreign
decides to jump in and close the deal
it's a risky move the big Kunk could
still be hungry
but the risk pays off
The Crafty crab will have plenty of room
to grow in his new home
the losing crabs could end up homeless
or worse
but other creatures rely on defense to
survive
[Music]
scorpions are built for battle
they have their own body armor
an exoskeleton that glows in the dark
[Music]
strong pincers coated with fine Hair
Sense prey and Crush enemies
they can survive in harsh conditions and
go as long as six months between meals
and then there's that venomous sting
they use it to immobilize their prey and
sometimes that prey is each other
[Music]
when one scorpion trespasses on
another's Turf it's time to Lock and
Load
their tails as swords each trying to
breach the other's defenses
if a sting penetrates the armor its
certain death
and digestion
scorpions can't eat solid food they have
to use enzymes to break it down
externally
the Victor cannibalizes its brother into
a scorpion soup
but the Carnage attracts a shrew and it
smells dinner
the small furry mammal looks harmless
but the Scorpion knows better
it beats a hasty retreat
shrews look like rodents but they are
far from vegetarians
to survive shrews must consume nearly
their entire body weight in food every
day and they're dangerous one of the few
mammals in the world armed with Venom
but the Scorpion has a formidable weapon
of its own
one well-placed sting can kill a shrew
instantly
[Music]
in the end the shrew's Lightning Fast
reflexes Prevail
this scorpion is about to be the main
course at a Thanksgiving dinner
and there won't be any leftovers
such quick reflexes make it tough for
any creature to tame the shrew
but this garter snake might have a
chance
[Music]
[Music]
it can eat almost anything rodents
reptiles insects fish birds and swallow
them whole
and this shrew would make a tasty snack
first the garter snake has to catch one
the Shrew lives Life in the Fast Lane
under stress its heart can beat up to 1
300 times a minute
to maintain all that energy it eats
constantly digging up worms and grubs in
this Rich garden soil
with its strong jaws and Swift bite the
snake seems to have the advantage
with the shrew's saliva can paralyze
prey
so in this fight
the first bite wins
the Shrew goes right for the neck
[Music]
snake's muscles go slack as the Venom
takes hold
[Music]
and the Shrew starts to eat him alive
size means nothing when you have the
right weapons
[Music]
battlefields The Winner Takes all it's
an evolutionary arms race or only the
fiercestor the fastest the bravest and
the most cunning survive
foreign
[Music]